editha a de Thea and working out that
okay price talk about pricing strategy
what is a pricing strategy for a new
product how can you convince the clients
that your price is right I think well
simply sort of question its you gotta
have differentiated you've got to have
at the end the day I think you have to
believe you product you have to leave
your mission and that's kind of what
this blends that we should probably do
another one around some of these topics
around brand pricing but with it without
a doubt again price in part of execution
and obviously it's party pricing
strategy so with that sort of thing test
drive it you know test driver they even
start talking to friends what what price
would people feel comfortable with test
it put it on the web if you're not
getting it right or know how to change
it but but I think a lot of a lot of
businesses when they start worry too
much about price and it's not the right
thing to worry about the right thing to
worry about is why would someone have a
compelling need for this product or
service why could I be very different
from anyone else and then honestly price
although that's good it's a good punch
to the stomach kind of realization
moment I would add that I think a lot of
entrepreneurs underpriced themselves a
lot of entrepreneurs just don't believe
that they're worth more and it's
stepping up to realize that hey I'm
adding value and and starting to go
after more ideal clients because you get
stuck in these like low paying clients
and low budgets and that starts to
affect your soft forth I feel like this
is all you can do where you could charge
more it's just about offering more value
to the right clients and so it's common
and when you start off a business you're
taking whoever you're trying to figure
it out but as you grow you want to think
about how can I provide more value to
better clients so you can increase your
prices and you know chase your dreams
make the matter if you want to make